all right lauren
yes lauren where did you grow up where
are you from originally
um i grew up in
carson california suburb of l.a yes and
tell me about your your parents your
family
um well
i got adopted at birth
my biological mother was six months
pregnant with me
and she
she died of a heroin overdose
they were able to get me out of her
stomach
i was two pounds two ounces
the doctors gave me 30 minutes to live
i was on the incubator
life support for nine months i died
twice as an infant
and then
the nurse that
nurtured me back to health ended up
adopting me
i got adopted by a mexican and
white family
and
so
i grew up with them
at the age of five my adopted dad died
and then two years later my adopted mom
died
when i was seven on mother's day
and so
i have
two adopted brothers and one adopted
sister
my adopted sister took legal
guardianship
um from the age of
7
to 12. she was quite a bit older
she was older than me
they were all older than me
and
so
what happened was
when i was 10
my adopted sister's boyfriend
molested and raped me and sodomized me
and beat me
for two years straight from the age of
10 to 12
and
my nephew
which is my sister's
son
uh i basically raised as a
as a
bigger sister to him
and
the boyfriend i call him the monster
was trying to
fondle on him so i would tell him to run
to our secret
hiding spot and don't come out until
till
i get him and so
i was basically like a sex slave
from the age of 10 to 12 and
um so what happened was
when i went to school elementary school
we um
wore
um
so you were you were doing that to
protect him yes i would jump in front of
him to
to save him
you know so
i would get punished instead
because he's two years younger than me
so one day when i went to elementary
school we had to
wear
uniforms
and i was wearing a
skirt
and
i had bruises and whelps in between my
thighs and
when the staff seen me
and
and said oh my god it took me to
the nurse's station and they made me get
undressed
and
once i got undressed she covered her
mouth like that and she started crying
and then i started crying
and she asked me what's going on and i
broke down and told her
so they removed me from my sister's
house
and
from the age of 12 to 18
i've been in and out of foster care
group homes
mental institutions
for adolescents
a runaway
i started to
be promiscuous at the age of 12.
i started selling my body
by the age of 15.
i started at dancing house parties
and then i got introduced to
pimping and hoeing
and then so i started selling my body at
15
and um
when
when
i turned 18
the foster system dcfs
basically kicked me out of the system
because
i had a bad
a bad
background
and they never told me anything about
like independent living and you know
going to school
you know um
i could stay up to about 24.
they didn't tell me none of that so when
i turned 18 they
kicked me to the streets and
i became homeless
i'm 32 about to be 33 next month and i
ran homeless
since the age of 18
living in streets prostituting
selling dope gang banging
and
i have three children
i have
two daughters and the son my oldest is
with
my adopted family
she's 13 and my son is 9
and my youngest daughter is 8 and they
both are adopted out
um
due to domestic violence and
my drug
usage
um
when i was pregnant with my youngest
daughter
i smoked dope all the way till i gave to
my water broke
and
when i went to the hospital
they seen that and they took her
away from me right away
and so i had visitations
with her
up to three months and when i went to go
see her
they told me did i get the message and i
said no
and
they basically said oh she got adopted
and i never got to say goodbye
and now she's eight and i don't know
nothing
um
anything about her and my son
uh i haven't seen since he was 15 months
old i wasn't using with him
actually when i lost custody of him
that's when
my whole life turned upside down i
started
smoking dope a lot slamming
just being in the streets and i became
pregnant with my youngest
london right after him
and
my daughter's dad was abusing me the
whole time feeding me dope
and uh holding me hostage
and um i took out all my anger on my
daughter
and
i've to this day it haunts me
because
you know i never grew up with no
mother figure
and so
it hurts me
to
just to know that my daughter's out
there and i have no idea if she's okay
or not
and
i'm still struggling with
my drug addiction and
what is your drug crystal meth and sherm
and
i've been slamming for eight years now
and
i've been smoking meth since i was 15
and so
for me to get my drugs
i prostitute myself to get by
and i panhandle
and
i went to prison when i was 18
for stealing out of stores to survive
and um
they violated me the first week
i was eight and a half months pregnant
with my oldest daughter and um
the first week i was there i gave birth
to her
so i had her at a
riverside regional medical center
and so my adopted cousin came and got
her
and she's been having her since she was
three days old and my daughter's 13.
i've been absent out of her life nine
years i just barely been
in her life for three years now
um trying to
get back what i lost you know all the
times where i've been running the
streets chasing at the guys
getting abused here and there
and thankfully my daughter
tells me that she loves me and she just
wants me to be okay
and
i'm just trying to find housie as we
speak i sleep in tents i i go to
different hotel rooms here to there
i have to give my body up just spend the
night
you know it's very uncomfortable
but um
yeah
and my birthday's gonna be next month on
the fourth i'll be 33 and
i'm just tired of living this life um
i want to do better for myself you know
if
i don't stop with the drugs and stuff
eventually it's going to kill me because
i have a lot of health problems
i'm overweight i'm diabetic i'm
asthmatic i have sleep apnea
scoliosis in the back
and
it takes a toll up on my body you know
so
i'm just
very thankful that i'm alive and well
you know i'm very spiritual woman
and even though i've been through a lot
in my life
i know god has a plan for me
and
all i need is to continue to have faith
in him
and everything will work out
your childhood
that was
before your parent your adopted parents
passed away
was that
you thought you were loved then yes
my adopted mother
she loved me she she
saved my life she nurtured me back to
health and i believe god took her on
mother's day
because she done
she did her job as far as
helping me you know this was a nurse yes
a nurse at the hospital
and
she was born
uh
april 10 1932 so she'd be in her 90's
right now
and um just recently a couple days ago
my adopted brother just passed away
and um
so
i'm still grieving from that you know i
don't really
have
my family
in my corner due to my
my choices of
my background
my choice of living in the streets and
stuff
so they kind of washed their hands
on me
so the only ones that i have support
is my cousin her husband and my daughter
and
i'm very thankful that i have them
because other than that
i would have nothing
and i'm trying to find my biological
father but
i'm getting older so it's kind of
getting pointless i'm getting
kind of frustrated at the time because
i'm like
i was a lost cause you know
my sister's boyfriend robbed me of my
innocence at the age of ten
but unfortunately
they gave him a double life sentence and
he got murdered in
prison
and um so
that's one thing i don't have to
think about anymore you know but my
sister is still out there and one of my
other brothers still out there
and so i'm
really lonely you know and
i choose to deal with different kind of
guys to
cuff for me you know because i'm very
vulnerable
and
and it's kind of disturbing because i
have to get my body up
just
just to
get that sense of companionship for the
moment and i know i'm better than that
but
thank god i don't have no hiv or aids or
anything
just despite my diabetes and stuff i'm
pretty healthy
for the most part and
i just take it one day at a time
what emotions do you go through this has
been such a hard life for you i go
through ups and downs for the most part
i'm depressed
majority of the time
because i'm like
why me you know i have a good heart
i give back to people
i go infinity and beyond
you know to help others
even though like
they dog me out they disrespect me they
treat me like
booboo and
and
you know i just
take that time to just know that i'm a
better person each day and i
and i strive to fight
for what's right you know i'm an
aquarius so
a very uh
intellectual person and
uh i'm a natural born leader i fight for
what's right and
i just keep on trying every day you know
as day goes by
i just prayed to the lord that
um
i would stop my addiction
and that i would get
in somewhere
i just talked to somebody earlier about
getting emergency housing
and so
she said she will call me tomorrow
[Music]
at two
to three o'clock
to
give me an application to fill out
to see where i can
go from there but from now
i sleep in a tent
and i go different spots downtown
and it's really scary because i don't
have no boyfriend or nothing so you know
but what do you worry about what are you
afraid of
i'm afraid of dying in the streets all
alone
um i don't have no id i don't have no
social security card you know
i have a phone but
um
if something
bad were to happen to me it's like i'm a
lost cause you know i'd be another jane
doe
and that's my most fear of like
something bad happening to me out here
while i'm trying to get my life together
so i just pray and
i just think one day at a time is this
your lowest point right now
yeah i'm at rock bottom because i'm like
running out of options
and
like i'm tired of living
any streets you know i'm getting older
my my daughter is getting older and
it's like if something doesn't open up
soon i don't know
the outcome would it be you know and i
don't want to
be another
statistic
statistic
out in the streets you know
another jane doe
and
i want to be somebody i want to
i would like to go to school i want to
do american sign language
i would like to be a mentor to troubled
teenage
foster kids
just to give them hope that there is
another way out
other than prostituting gay banging
having kids early
you know
nobody saved me when i was in foster
care so
that's one of the things i would like to
do is give back and
save somebody else's life and
i think that would save me you know
overcoming
my biggest fear is
becoming a nobody
you know i just want to give back to
society and just
just show them that there is
love and there's hope and there's
there's
you know
there's
a different kind of life out there
rather than
what we know
and if i can
tell my testimony and
and save a person's life
then
i know i did a good job you know i even
want to write my own book
it's gonna it's gonna call take a walk
in my shoes
and my biggest
my biggest
role model is dave pelzler
he wrote the book a child called it
and ever since i wrote read that book
it kind of gave me inspiration to tell
my story
and
to let people know that just because we
go through things doesn't mean
we have to become monsters or
you know
become evil
and that there is success out there for
us as long as we're willing to take it
um
i don't think this is the end of the
road i just
don't know when there will be a
breakthrough for me so i just
like i said pray every day and just take
one day at a time
yeah you've had so many rough breaks
do you feel like life is unfair
yeah i feel like life is unfair because
first off my
mother took the easy way out
you know she she didn't make it and she
left me
struggling for each breath that i take
and
i have a lot of mental issues
problems and a lot of health issues and
i'm just
thankful that i'm alive you know because
i could have been gone a long time ago
and i
i believe in the higher power and i know
god has something in store for me
i just don't know when
and he's been
he's been holding on to me
since i came out the wound you know i'm
a natural-born fighter you know and
it takes a lot
from a person
to
fight each and every day
and
that's why i know that there's something
good going to happen
through this you know
as long as i keep fighting
for what's right and
and taking the steps to
to becoming a better person
i think god will open doors for me
i just got to be patient and just
sit back and be still
and
not allow people to
to break me down even worse than i am
because i am vulnerable and
it is hard for me to say no
when it comes to drugs i'm not as strong
as
i should be but i'm working on myself
what do you think the biggest factor was
in your
the situation you're in today
was it your
well i strive because
of my daughter you know
she gives me hope every day yeah but
what do you think was the biggest
setback in your childhood
um
just not having no love no guidance no
support after your parents passed away
after my parents passed away it just
went downhill from there
my adopted sister
i found out she was getting
beat and and
raped too as well so she
threw herself in and worked she was a rn
nurse
at harvard ucla
um hospital have you ever had jobs
i never had a job
i'm on gr by the grace of god
and they're working on my ssi as we
speak now you've been living on the
streets for how long
i've been on the street since
uh
since the age of 16 but legally 18
and i'm 32 now
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um
just be myself
no matter what happens no matter what
comes my way
i know god wouldn't put nothing on me
that i can't
handle so
i take that and i run with it you know
um
every time i get knocked down i dust
myself off and i just keep on trying
because i know if i
if i dust myself off and i keep on going
something has to
happen good you know
but as long as i lay there and i feel
sorry for myself
then i'm not going to get anywhere
all right lauren well thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you so much
you should write a book
yes
thank you very much
you